aunque el acuerdo comercial del break si
te da inicio a una nueva etapa está
lejos de ser la última todos los
embajadores de los 27 países de la unión
europea aprobaron las regulaciones de la
nueva relación comercial con reino unido
ahora que este país se separará
totalmente del bloque común al terminar
el 2020
luz verde para el break shit los
embajadores de la unión europea
aprobaron por unanimidad la aplicación
provisional del acuerdo de comercio y
cooperación entre la unión europea y el
reino unido- a partir del primero de
enero de 2021 esta aprobación es
provisional para que el acuerdo
comercial entre en vigor a partir del
primero de enero faltan más
ratificaciones el martes la unión
europea pasará por escrito su decisión y
el parlamento británico debatirá del 30
de diciembre si aprueba del acuerdo lo
mismo hará el parlamento europeo entre
el 18 y el 21 de enero la institución
sólo podrá votar en bloque para decirle
sí o no al pacto total sin hacerle
ningún cambio se espera que el acuerdo
pase todas las formalidades que restan
sin ningún inconveniente
acabo de hablar con el presidente del
consejo europeo charles michel acoge con
satisfacción la importancia del acuerdo
entre reino unido y la unión europea
como nuevo punto de partida para nuestra
relación entre soberanos iguales
el primer ministro agregó que aspira a
trabajar junto con la unión europea en
las prioridades compartidas como el
cambio climático